the brave people of Ukraine have been
awarded the 2022 Sakura prize for
freedom of thought for their fight for
freedom and Independence in the face of
Russian aggression on the 24th of
February 2022 Russia invaded Ukraine
attacking military and civilian targets
alike
the people of Ukraine led by their
president are still standing strong and
United
foreign
foreign
representatives of the paramedic group
angels of Tyra the yellow ribbon civil
resistance movement the center for civil
liberties the state Emergency Services
of Ukraine and the mayor of militar were
present to receive the prize
the message from Europe has been clear
we stand with Ukraine we will not look
away
the Ukrainian people are not just
fighting a war of independence but
fighting a war of values the values
which underpin our life in the European
Union the European Parliament has
repeatedly condemned The Invasion and
Russian brutality it supported EU
sanctions against Moscow and economic
support for Keith
by awarding ukrainians the 2022 Sakura
of prize MEPS recognized their bravery
in defending their sovereignty rights
and freedoms is
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]